good afternoon my name is Lieutenant
Greg fennis the Greg
p-h-e-n-i-s the Las Vegas Metropolitan
Police Department I'm here to brief you
today on a shooting that happened in the
8900 block of Jamie Lee Court
at about four o'clock P.M this afternoon
for lbmpd communications center received
several 9-1-1 calls about a shooting
that had happened in the neighborhood
responding officers
arrived and found two juvenile victims
suffering from gunshot wounds they were
both transported to Centennial Hills
Hospital and then later transferred to
UMC trauma
one of them is suffering from
life-threatening injuries the other is
suffering from non-life-threatening
injuries our detectives are currently on
scene investigating this shooting and
they're coming through video to try to
identify the suspects in the suspect
vehicle who are not yet in custody
and I can take any questions
it just seems so Random to two kids I
mean any adults hurt no ma'am just two
juveniles that were shot we don't know
yet what led up to the shooting we just
know uh that two juveniles were shot and
they were appears they were standing in
the street when it happened and when you
say that they were taken to the hospital
who drove them to the hospital were they
able to drive themselves no there was
self-transported we believed by family
to Centennial Hills Hospital and then
they were transferred to UMC trauma
after that okay is there a weapon found
no weapons were found
that's correct
I don't know how many were found in the
street there were several in the street
any other questions how can people help
if anyone has any additional information
on this shooting please call Crime
Stoppers at 385-555
thank you neighbors or residents here
said they saw the vehicle the make a
model the color how many people were in
the car that's all part of the
investigation ma'am our detectives are
on scene and they'll identify and speak
with any any neighbors are willing to
speak thank you very much